Irene cuéntanos exactamente dónde te
encuentras Y qué es lo que se está
oyendo en la capital del país
un helicóptero quizás un avión que ha
caído sobre la ciudad digamos es un
vehículo que estaba en el aire y
ha caído en el centro de la ciudad Esta
es la explosión que hemos oído en este
momento y que nos llevó a tomar la
decisión de bajar al refugio
imaginamos que es la directiva que os
habían dado en cuanto se oigan
explosiones bajar a los refugios por
protección se ha escuchado solamente una
explosión de momento se han escuchado
varias
de estos Refugio
de internet no no funciona muy bien los
datos
y pues nada estamos a la espera de
entender y tener más información sobre
lo que ha ocurrido en la ciudad es se
esperaba una un ataque a las 3 de la
mañana esto no ha ocurrido
Sin embargo a las 4
en este momento y es la tónica general
dentro de la ciudad Se han podido ver
imagenes también en el metro de kiev de
la gente buscando Refugio de las bombas
damos por hecho que es la tónica general
en la ciudad la gente refugiándose bajo
tierra
Sí sí es así así como lo estás contando
la gente está bajo tierra está mucha
familia aceptaron por pasar toda la
noche
tranquila en la última parte de la
jornada de ayer no hubo y y lo hicieron
por lógicamente por miedo también
la noche
es lo que está haciendo la población en
este clima de de favor y nerviosismo que
crea esta situación en la que como en
todas las guerras hay muchas
informaciones que circulan y muchas son
difíciles
en las personas